[Music]
what's up guys thanks for joining us
again here at the playstation
competition center for more videos on
soul calibur 6.
rip and markman here once again this
time we're going to be going over the
basics of attacking blocking and moving
now attacking is more than just matching
buttons on a controller it's important
to know how each attack works in
conjunction with each other to become a
better player
let's see how they work there are three
different attack buttons in soul calibur
6
horizontal attacks vertical attacks and
kicks
the game will use the shorthand of a b
and k to talk about these since it's
describing the moves a lot easier
there's also a guard button called g to
block attacks and soul calibur you must
hold the guard bite
holding back on the controller does not
work for the most part attacks and soul
calibur can hit at three different
heights
we call these high mid and low
in order to defend against high and mid
attacks hold the guard button while
standing
to block lows you must hold down your
controller along with guard
importantly if you are crouch blocking
mid attacks will hit you
but high attacks will always miss over
your head ah but to fully understand how
attacks are built in soul calibur you
must also understand something called
the eight way run
soul calibur is especially famous for
its fast fluid movement and eight way
run exemplifies this
simply hold any direction on the
controller to move in that direction
including diagonally
or double tap a direction to move more
quickly you can weave
in and out of your opponent's attacks
and even access special attacks that are
only available
while running in certain directions this
is important because movement is crucial
for defense
vertical attacks are often strong
offensive tools that hit mid but they
are almost always dodged by simply
moving up or down
horizontal attacks meanwhile are great
at hitting people trying to move and
they're often some of your fastest
attacks
but many horizontals are high attacks so
you can just crouch onto them
and then to hit someone who is crouching
you should use a mid-hitting vertical
attack again
this forms an interesting mind game that
is pretty unique to soul calibur
since movement is so effortless and
crucial to your strategy
if you're running into some difficult
attacks think about how moving out of
the way might help you handle it
is also useful of course but it has some
drawbacks if you block too many attacks
your health bar will start to flash
yellow
and then red eventually guarding a
powerful attack on a red health bar will
shatter your guard completely
leaving you wide open for a huge attack
if you press l1 on your controller
you'll perform a powerful vertical
attack
called the brake attack this attack is
especially good at damaging your
opponent's guard if it's blocked
but because the l1 brake attack is a
vertical attack you can sidestep it and
avoid blocking it entirely
using horizontal attacks to catch
players that are moving around or using
vertical attacks to catch players that
are scared to move is a core aspect of
fundamental
soul calibur 6 gameplay right and
instead of just button mashing you know
try to react to what your opponents are
doing
are they crouching a lot are they using
eight-way run a lot maybe they're using
horizontal attack or vertical attack
paying attention to this and reacting
accordingly will help you a lot more in
the long term
that'll do it for this episode this
tutorial was made in partnership with
the playstation competition center team
you can sign up for their open series
competitions on compete.playstation.com
subscribe to the bne esports channel for
more tutorials and soul calibur 6
content